il ya bien longtemps les sirènes se sont
tus les ouvriers sont partis de l'usiné
renault il ne reste que ça des ateliers
vide des murs décrépis et de la mauvaise
herbe
mais à y regarder de plus près ici l'air
de n'est pas si mauvaise c'est le
premier level de la mafia forte et la
terre comme un jour tu mettais découvert
ils sont une douzaine à cultiver
amoureusement desjardins desjardins au
pied de l'usure qui jadis appartenait
aux ouvriers tir il y avait des ouvriers
renault ici que des gars ne la bat yam
un forgeron des fondeurs des des
tauliers l'éthique quand il sortait de
l'île seguin ibn un peu se détendent ici
en faisant un peu de jardin ce temps est
révolu
mais depuis 47 ans monsieur fernand
attribue les jardins à tous ceux qui
s'en montre digne
n'aviez-vous pas combien qu'est ce que
c'est a laissé la foule a dit
jean-françois et directeur financier
il a dû montrer patte blanche pour
pouvoir vous fallait que je montre que
j'étais quand même motivé pour avoir
pour avoir un jardin montré que j'étais
prêt à m'investir je veux que je n'y
connaissais pas grand-chose qui étaient
exactes enfin tout le monde s'est
montrée pertinemment ce bon professeur
pour m'apprendre et puis de plein de
bonne volonté et même si la bonne
volonté ne suffit pas toujours à faire
passer une salade d'herbes et c'est
valable mais ça l'est parce que c'est le
moment de lancer le voyez la gêne et des
erreurs dit ben oui jours après voilà ce
que ça donne mais j'ai des 40 ça
commence à germer loin j'ai des
potimarrons et ça c'est du bonheur si
lui et puis il ya ceux qui se mettent
une douce car après tout le jardin
secret le jardin d'ici voyez vous en
avez l'autre
la bouche est folle pas grand chose là
alors je nettoyais j16 jeu là c'est moi
qui s'occupe de ma cabane je nettoyais
lapin lalart toutes les semaines
du bonheur rien que du bonheur de pied
du zim et pour pas grand chose
chacun de nous sa parcelle 800 francs
l'année leur jardinet
à